[Applause]
he's made no secret that he wanted the
job
[Applause]
[Music]
crying is Rishi really ready to take it
on
sunak has certainly fought for it
labeled by some as the man who took out
Boris Johnson in the summer simply
impossible for a Chancellor and prime
minister not to be on the same page when
it comes to economic policy
now the result then took on Liz trust to
become Prime Minister his trust is
elected as the leader of the
conservative Union as fast and lost
publicly he has stopped short of saying
I Told You So as her economic plans
failed
his supporters say now is his time
Rishi sunak thank you Mr Speaker
am I right honorable friend only an MP
since 2015 he is far from a seasoned
political heavyweight let me tell you a
story
about a young woman almost a lifetime
ago his last campaign was about us
getting to know him better telling us
more about his childhood their story
didn't end there but that is where my
story began and ultimately fighting back
against some difficult criticism about
his own personal wealth his time as an
investment banker and the controversy
over whether his wife was paying the
right tax issues that he could not Shake
in that first battle for number 10. and
I think the British people judge people
by their character and by their actions
not by their bank account
his political stock had been propelled
by the pandemic we will support incomes
we will support businesses
and we will help you protect your loved
ones
we will do whatever it takes as
Chancellor he became the face of the
furlough scheme and eat out to help out
rolling his sleeves up is a vital part
of the top team outwardly it seemed
United to get the country through it
but increasingly fractures were showing
they didn't see eye to eye undermining
the likelihood of a Johnson sunac
comeback
Rishi sunak and his team have been
careful not to make this latest bid to
become Prime Minister to personal we're
going to be in the next p.m a former
chancellor who doesn't just want his
eyes on the books now prepared to take
charge at a time when the stakes could
not be any higher Brianna Mills Sky News